god send me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis
kanye west is never shy about his
feelings especially when it comes to his
estranged wife kim kardashian's former
beau p davidson and in the wake of
keith's split a source tells e.t pete's
been in therapy for years but now he's
taking it a step further pete is seeking
quote trauma therapy help in large part
due to kanye's constant threats and
public attacks
there it is
don't interrupt
just because it's no love
that violent music video it's kanye's
track with the game called easy and when
it first dropped in march pete
reportedly reached out to yay to settle
the beef since deleted screenshots of
the alleged convo between the two
circulated online pete asking kanye to
calm down while praising kim for being a
great mother
he's just super genuine
and kim well she made it clear on her
hulu docu series the kardashians she
doesn't agree with how kanye handles his
feelings like all i can do is control
how i react to something i can't control
how he treats me
and since news broke that keat is done
so after nine months of dating the
rapper reacted to the split online
sharing a fake cover of the new york
times with the fake headline that read
skeet davidson dead at age 28. it has
since been deleted from his instagram
and aside from social media a source
tells eta is way happier with pete out
the picture quote he never took their
relationship seriously or felt good
about pete being around
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
as for how pete's been handling the
breakup another source tells e.t pete is
bummed things didn't work out with kim
but he is focused on the future in terms
of his career and personal life in fact
he's been busy working in australia
filming his new movie wizards check out
his relaxed look on set wearing a shirt
that says i feel like
whether it's for the role or reflecting
his current mood pete's shirt says a lot
meanwhile we're told kim still wants to
remain friends but is ready to jump back
in the dating pool
need to get out there and pete well our
source says his close friends already
want to set him up on dates
[Music]
you